they love the deep water and the food
here is plentiful hundreds of dolphins
and whales use the tanyon straight in
the Philippines as a resting ground now
they could provide a source of income
annabelle plantier works for bio fin an
organization that advises governments
worldwide on how to find the funds to
protect the environment and biodiversity
we can always say that the Balkans are
beautiful but I think what is also
important for a developing country like
ours is to put a value to our natural
heritage so that all of us will be able
to realize its economic value dolphin
tours for tourists could help bring in
money which in turn could be used for
their protection the wildlife reserve
needs more Rangers too much illegal
fishing using dynamite is still taking
place and that kills all living
organisms and destroys habitats but
Ranger leonito Torre says it's hard to
combat the problem no no I'm gonna hold
on a moment we get threats when we
report illegal fishermen they threatened
to kill us that happens a lot
relativity's nami moon electorate lagana
in the meantime they are doing their
best to repair the damages they've been
growing corals and replanting them in
degraded areas this not only provides
food for the whales and dolphins but
cleaner water for those who live from
the reserve such as oyster fishermen
anzlé silva and his family
Baron Apple in handling good not happen
for big daddy it's very important to me
to protect this water because we need it
for our livelihood we have to ensure
that our corals aren't harmed or
destroyed hundreds of species live amid
the corals many of which are endangered
such as the tridacna gigas a giant clam